I fell into production design by
accident I was trained as an illustrator
and I just wanted to make pictures and
at the time the illustration market was
starting to wind down a little bit I had
a hard time finding jobs and I found one
in animation and I just kept it for like
30 years and then it became a production
designer not after I mean like somewhere
in there I think people think that a
production designer sits in their room
and draws all day long that's not the
case at all I mean I I barely draw and
barely paint at all at work I'm
overseeing a team of incredibly talented
artists that do magnificent work but
mostly I look over their shoulders and
go that's great this is almost good do
this do this do this and it's a
collaborative effort but probably the
last thing that I do is sit in my room
with my headphones on painting all day
in animation a production designer at
DreamWorks anyway we'll start with the
beginning of the film and will escort
the visuals of the film all the way
through to the final color timing so
we'll be involved with part of the with
the early development work will see to
it that all the sets and the characters
are designed and built well once the
scenes are animated they go into
lighting we oversee the lighting with
the VFX soup and DP if there's one and
then escort the whole thing through to
the very end process so it's a really a
overseeing of the visual look of the
film from beginning to end
you